minnerath fast week got three pimples on
the face bing-bang-boom
pimples all the way of your body telling
you to get your ugly ass back in your
house
cut my finger - got me booboo wanna kiss
it wanna keep it with the food Oh what
is going on YouTube now I'm pretty sure
a lot of us have heard or have been
watching the Sochi Olympics but I've
read and I've heard through the
grapevine there's a little bit of
controversy mmm Oh a no sign no Allison
read that a lot of Libyans are buying a
lot of condoms out there and you know
what fair trade they're practicing safe
sex kids use a [ __ ] cotton now for
those of you who don't know South Korea
has their country's pride placed into
the very talented you not Kim you're not
big huh
but while reading all these articles is
seeing that there's a petition being
signed they had the judging system in
the Sochi Olympics investigated because
you're not Kim apparently one silver and
people are mad about that but you guys
want to know my opinion about this
proposed scandal you already know what
it is
LGI baby let's get it let's go now
before I get into this let's be real for
a moment what the [ __ ] do any of us know
about ice skating now a lot of us out
there who are watching the ice skating
competition at the Olympics are only
watching because it's the Olympics so I
love how everybody is now criticizing
and many comments about ice skating as
if they know and wants to sport their
whole life
if you don't know [ __ ] technique and
difficulty check pull look at that
triple axel look at her form flawless
[ __ ] you don't watch that [ __ ] are you
talk about technique and form it aren't
when you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
looking at huh you see that right there
flawless a word of what about oh you
know that uh jump Alutiiq Wonka dominoes
they actually this [ __ ] up you know what
you guys are you guys are like me when I
drink wine in front of rich white people
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm not
right like I do you know this one has a
nice one Geo Robo with the aromatic
fruity finish at the energy palette am i
right hmm yeah I can see that cheers
[ __ ] bought it let's leave today don't
know what the hell's in I just want my
people like me I heard that for every
immigrant that befriends a white person
a baby unicorn is born even if you want
her to win just because she's Korean
that's cool too
just be real real talk in the Olympics
both of us don't judge by the end we
just judged by which country we're
rooting for you should have seen my
facebook when you not did not win gold
every Korean was outraged yeah your oh
my god oh my god Akane
Bernie Russian cheetah multi huge won't
even give a [ __ ] about technique if they
lose you automatically blame it on
witchcraft that's the devil that's a
harry potter magic I'm gonna call
Captain America now if you want to know
my real opinion about this I saw both
performances now like a majority of us I
don't really watch ice skating on a
regular basis so I don't really know if
one person set was better or more
difficult than the other I'm ice skating
ignorant all I know is that I can't do
any of the [ __ ] that they're doing and
they just look like little little ice
fairies to me could you imagine me ice
skating that [ __ ] would be the ugliest
thing on earth if anything my big ass
would call that ice up so much sure that
whole skating way into a snow cone
bottom line and Lina something call the
set look dope but I did see a [ __ ] up a
few times now from reading about four or
five articles about this subject matter
it does seem that the scoring was a
little bit shady leading me to believe
that it might have been botched so if it
was shame on you [ __ ] now I
understand that heavy pride in one's
country is great but what do you
something under unfair circumstances I
mean what's the whole point it doesn't
change the fact that you didn't really
win the medal and it sucks to kind of
keep something that people will always
help you for the rest of your life so
just to put my two cents in if I was an
athlete I wouldn't want that
why because I didn't deserve it and it
doesn't really validate all the hard
work I put into my craft have I haven't
cheated sports you asked of course I did
I'm Sheamus his father choose daughter
one time when I was a kid I raced when
the neighbors down street and guess what
your boy won that team hell yes I did
right before we started we went down
like this far too directly this mouth
kid almost passed the [ __ ] out how to do
what I had to do well the Fed s pretty
kid slow [ __ ] nothing much has changed
watching the ice king competition at the
Olympics or room it would you all like
you doesn't meet when I drink right Ryan
what the [ __ ] is right when I drink all
right if I know each other to be better
if you guys want to talk about her I
don't put the beat one time when I was a
kid I raced when the neighbors got one
man well look at that triple axel rooms
gonna spit all over the [ __ ] place
there's a bit of cash bar oh it's
[ __ ] soft myself in the face [ __ ] I
bit my lip I'm bleeding out my mouth
because I stopped myself in the face get
your life together